اعلنت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
الخليل منطقه عسكريه مغلقه بعد مقتل
مستوطنه اسرائيليه واصابه مستوطن في اطلاق
نار لم يعرف منفذه قرب مجمع مستوطنات اربع
بالمدينه بالضفه الغربيه ياتي هذا بعد
يومين من مقتل مستوطنين اسرائيليين في
عمليه بالضفه لم يعثر على منفذها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما ابرز التغيرات في
نهج واساليب وادوات المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بالضفه الغربيه في ضوء زياده وزياده في
وتيره العمليات المسلحه ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه وما مدى ادراكت تل ابيب دوره
تصعيدها في ذلك
وكيف نقرا فشل سياسه القبضه الامنيه التي
تتبناها حكومه اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل
بما تضمنته من عمليات التوهل واقتحام في
المدن والمخيمات الفلسطينيه
وما موقف واشنطن مما يجري في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه جراء سياسه الاحتلال وما خطتها
واوراق الضغط التي تملكها لاعاده الهدوء
وتثبيت الاستقرار في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد يومين من عمليه لم يعثر بعد على
منفذها ادت لمقتل مستوطنين اسرائيليين في
بلده حواره بالضفه الغربيه لقيت مستوطنه
اسرائيليه حتفها واصيب اخر بجروح خطيره في
اطلاق نار قرب مجمع مستوطنات اربع بمدينه
الخليل جنوبيه الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعلنت مدينه
الخليل منطقه عسكريه مغلقه وسدت جميع
مداخلها
بالحواجز العسكريه كما اقتحمت قوه
الاحتلال حسب مراسل الجزيره منطقه الفحص
جنوبي مدينه الخليل وبلده بيت امر وقريه
بيت سامت بحتا بحثا عن منفذ العمليه التي
تاتي في سياق عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي ارتفعت وتيرتها بالتوازي مع تصعيد
حكومه اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل
استهدافها الفلسطينيين في القدس والضفه
الغربيه
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه باليمين نتنياهو
اتهم ايران ومن سماهم اتباعها بالوقوف
وراء الهجوم الارهابيه الاخير في الخليل
بحسب وصفه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا في الجزء
الاول من هذه الحلقه من تل ابيب جولان
برهوم الباحث والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي على ان ينضم الينا فيما بعد
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي ومن واشنطن
نبدا معك جولان برهوم في هذا الجزء الاول
ونبدا بتصريحات او تصريح بنيامين نتنياهو
الذي قال فيه ما يجري يتم بتوجيه خارجي
واسرائيل هي في ذروه هجوم ارهابي ممول من
ايران
واتباعها اليس في هذا انكار يتجاهل فيه
بنيامين نتنياهو كل الاسباب التي ادت الى
هذا التصيد
بدايه تحياتي لك وللجميع وشكرا لكم على
هذا الاستضافه الكريمه انظري ماذا حصل
اليوم وهذا معروف غير متعلق بالاحتلال او
هذه الحكومه حكومه متطرفه نعم او لا او
المازق السياسي القاسي في اسرائيل هناك
محاولات من قبل ايران اذا تكون دوله
فلسطينيه او لا تكن دوله فلسطينيه في يوم
من الايام هناك محاولات من قبل ايران
المرشد العالي التي لا تقبل دوله اسرائيل
وخصوصا هذه الايام ربما لا تفهم الوضع
السياسي في الاسرائيلي ابونا في هذه
الهجمه ايران هي جزء شريحه مركزيه التي
هذه الشريحه اولا ايران هي عدو العرب هي
عدو مشترك للعرب واليهود في هذه المنطقه
للاسف الشديد نعم اقول بكل المسؤوليه حقا
ما الى الفلسطينيه
للجميع ما الدلائل والاثباتات التي تسند
كلام بنيامين نتنياهو من ان ايران وراء كل
ما يجري
غير فقط ايران لكن بدون شك ايران يا عنصر
عامل مركزي الذي يريد ان
يستمر التطور ضد مواطنين اسرائيليين غير
غير من اليوم لكن اذا تريدين او تريدين
الثبوت او اكبر واحسن ادله ان ايرانيه على
دول العرب انظروا الوضع في الشرق الاوسط
من يشوش الاستقرار في لبنان من الاستقرار
في سوريا
يعني انت تنكر كل الاسباب التي ادت الى
هذا التصعيد ليس هناك اغتيالات ليس هناك
اقتحامات ليس هناك هدم للمنازل ليس هناك
140 فلسطيني قتلوا منذ بدايه هذه السنه
سنه 2023 كل هذا مش موجود ايران فقط
[ضحك]
لا انظر يا بناء بناء بناء بيوت احياء
عمارات في ارض اجدادنا هذا لا يخالف مع
القانون الدولي القانون الضوئي يتحدث
باختصار لو سمحتي فقط جم
له وبتحدث على انسحاب من اراضي بدون تعرف
غرق الاراضي واحنا قد انسحبنا انسحبنا من
سيناء وانسحبنا للاسف الشديد من غزه جزء
من ارض اسرائيل
جميله انا كشرت الى الانسحاب من غزه طيب
ما الفائده اذا من التصعيد في غزه وجرح
عدد من الفلسطينيين اعتقد تجاوز 15 مصاب
فلسطيني خرجوا فقط للتظاهر من وراء السياج
ما الفائده اذا من وراء كل ذلك لماذا كل
هذا التصعيد المجاني برايك
انظري
اعظم شعب اسرائيل مؤمن بحق اليهود في ارض
اسرائيل نعم بالاضافه هناك اجماع في
اسرائيل عن انسحاب من غزه التهجير من غاز
تلك الايام هذا عمليه كانت غلطه بدون
بدون شك ولكن انا مؤمن اعمال البربريه
الوحشيه والسيده الكريمه كل واحد اقلام
فهمان يستطيع ان يقول في التقاضي بالاضافه
ان لا يوجد اي مبرر لقتل موطنين شيوخ
ستات اولاد رجال غير مسلحين ولو بالاسم
مقاومه انا مؤمن بالسنه ولكن هذه الاعمال
كما تقول انت بتعبير الكلام عقلان وفهمان
بكلماتك ماذا عن الجانب الفلسطيني الذين
يقتلون من الجانب الفلسطيني يتحدث عن 140
فلسطيني منذ بدايه السنه
انظري انا لا اعرفها واستطيع ان اقول
بالنسبه لهذه المعلومات ربما هذه
المعلومات هي معلومات مغلوطه نعم نحن
نقاتل لا نقتل نحن نقاتل مقربين ولكن
بالنسبه للفلسطينيين نحن نريد فتح الحواجز
نحن نريد حياء مشتركه انا غير مؤمن
بالضاله الفلسطينيه مستقله دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله تكون مركز ارهابي الذي التي هذه
الدوله تعهد على الشعوب العربيه وتكون
مدعومه من قبل ايران ولكن انا مؤمن
بالحياء مشتركه انا مؤمن بالاستثمارات
والدعم الاقتصادي
كلامك يخالف تماما كل القوانين الدوليه
وقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه لماذا تقولي
ربما ربما المقاومه الفلسطينيه تشكرك لانه
هذا الخطاب ربما هو الذي اعاد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الى الى مجدها الان ودعني اشير
الى ما تقوله الجبهه الشعبيه من ان عمليات
اربع في الخليل اثبتت قدره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على اختراق الاجراءات الامنيه
المعقده لا يسعنا الوقت
الاستمرار في نقاشا ومعنا ايضا ضيفاني
اخران شكرا لك جولان برهوم ونستقبل الان
ضيفينا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي امين عام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ومن واشنطن
برات بروين مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في
البيت الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس الاسبق
باراك اوباما اهلا بكما وقبل ذلك اشير الى
ان ثمانيه فلسطينيين قتلوا في عفوا اصيبوا
فلسطينيين برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
وصفت حاله احدهم بالخطيره وقال الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني انهم سقطوا خلال اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال بلده بيتا جنوب نابلس بحثا
عن منفذ عمليه حواره اما في غزه واثناء
التظاهر خلف الاسوار المنيعه الفاصله بين
القطاع واسرائيل فقد اصيب خمسه عشر
فلسطينيا برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
مشاركتهم في فعاليه بمناسبه ذكرى احراق
المسجد
الاقصى اعود لترحيب بضيفينا اذا وابدا معك
دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي او لما رايك بما قاله ضيفنا
جولان برهوم قبل قليل
انا سارد على ما قالوا نتنياهو وما يقوله
الاسرائيليون عموما هم يدعون ان المشكله
مع ايران ودعيني اذكر انه على مدار 75 عام
من التطهير العرقي ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
النكبه و56 عام من الاحتلال الاطول في
التاريخ الحديث
الاسرائيليون دائما يبحثوا عن دوله
ليحملوها المسؤوليه كان زمان يقول ان
المشكله الاتحاد السوفيتي ثم كانت المشكله
مصر في زمن عبد الناصر ثم اصبحت المشكله
سوريا ثم العراق والان ايران وغدا ربما
سيتحدث عن اذربيجان هذا كله هروب من جوهر
المشكله جوهر المشكله الاحتلال الاجرامي
القامع للشعب الفلسطيني
229 شهيد منذ بدايه هذا العام منهم 38 طفل
قتلهم جيش الاحتلال قبل قليل والان يتداول
الناس الفيديوهات هذا الفيديو اطلق جيش
الاحتلال النار على شاب على راسه وهو يركض
هاربا من الاحتلال اطلقوا عليه الرصاص من
الخلف واوقعوا به جراح خطيره وقد يستشهد
في بلده بيتا بالاضافه الى سته اخرين
اصيبوا بالرصاص الحي و15 اخرين اصيبوا في
غزه نحن نتعرض لهجوم اجرامي نتعرض اليوم
الخليل الان في هذه اللحظه في حصار خانق
يمس حياه 800 الف فلسطيني ليس فقط في
المدينه بل في كل المناطق المحيطه بها نحن
نتعرض لاحتلال واستيطان استعماري اجرامي
مخالف لكل القوانين الدوليه ومس بكرامتنا
واذلال على 650 حاجز اجرامي اسرائيلي وفوق
كل ذلك يقطع عنا المياه
ويمارسوا اسوا نظام تمييز عنصري في تاريخ
البشريه الحديث ماذا ينتظر طبعا الشعب
الفلسطيني سيقاوم وسواء كان في دوله
الفلسطينيين هنا او هناك او لم تكن هذا
الشعب سيقاوم هذا الظلم وسيقاوم هذا
الاضطهاد وهذا الشعب الذي لا يريد
الاسرائيليون ان يروه يجب ان يعرفوهم
صدامهم مع الشعب الفلسطيني وليس نعم رد
اتحول الى
اليوم هناك مقاومه فلسطينيه ترد وترد بقوه
وطورت اساليب ردها وادواتها كيف تنظر
واشنطن الى هذا التصيد والى رد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
ان واشنطن تراقب بعين ملؤها القلق لان هذا
الامر قد يستمر
بالتصعيد وهذا
سيتطلب المزيد من التدخل الفعال من جانب
اداره بايدن كما ان هذا التطور ياتي في
وقت رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو وحكومته قد
احرقوا الكثير من الجسور مع دوائر القرار
في واشنطن
طبعا
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده اعطت اسرائيل مجالا
للتحرك لكن هذا المجال لم يعد موجودا
وقائما هناك ما ادى الى خسائر في الارواح
في صفوف في الطرفين وسوف يؤدي الى المزيد
من التدخل من راس ربما لكن على
الاسرائيليين ان يدركوا محبه ذلك لانهم من
الان في موقف صعب
والمزيد من القتلى والمزيد من التصعيد قد
يؤدي الى المزيد من التدخل والذات الفعل
من جانب لكن اذا كانت واشنطن تدرك كل ذلك
لماذا هي جالسه وتتفرج
السبب لان هذه هي الاجراءات العملياتيه
المعياريه المتبعه عندما يتعلق الامر
بسياسه الغرب وسياسه واشنطن اسرائيل
او يسمحون لاسرائيل
بالتصرف والتحرك بقدر كبير من المرونه لكن
هذا الامر
تغير تدريجيا على مدى السنوات الماضيه
بالتاكيد لدى الديمقراطيين واداره بايدن
ان هناك اصوات تطالب لممارسه مواقف اكثر
تشددا بينما في الجانب الجمهوري في
الكونجرس هناك دعم قوي الكل يدعم نتنياهو
وسياساته وتكتيكاته على العدوانيه هذا
يخلق
سياسيه مثيره للانتباه في الجانب
الديمقراطي الدعم يقل وهو اقل بكثير مما
كان في الماضي القريب لاسرائيل هذا يعطي
اداره بايدن هامشا اكبر على الحركه للضغط
على اداره
نتنياهو ليفعل المزيد لكن علينا ان نرى
نتنياهو ان يتصرف بحذر لانه لا يحظى
بالكثير من الدعم في صفوف اداره بايدن
البرغوثي نعود الى الى هذا التصعيد والى
هذه الاحداث في الميدان حماس قالت اننا
امام انتفاضه وثوره كبيره يخوضها الشعب
الفلسطيني برايك ما مدى دقه هذا التوصيف
لما يجري الان
هذا توصيف دقيق اخت خديجه بل اكثر من ذلك
انا اقول ان الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وفلسطين عموما في حاله انتفاضه حقيقيه
تجري على شكل موجات منذ عام 2015
عام 2015 كان لحظه تحول في ادراك ووعي
الشعب الفلسطيني بانه لا مناص من المقاومه
والكفاح والنضال وانه لا مراهنه لا على
مفاوضات ولا على تدخل خارجي واقتنع الشعب
الفلسطيني بانه ما حكى جلدك مثل ظفرك ولن
ياتي احد لمساعدتنا والولايات المتحده
واداراتها المتعاقبه تتحمل مسؤوليه كبيره
جدا فيما يجري لانها امتنعت عن فرض اي
اجراء عقابي ضد اسرائيل على توسيعها
للمستوطنات الاستعماريه التي باعتراف
الولايات المتحده هي تدمر اصلا اي فرصه
لقيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله اذا نحن في
حاله انتفاضه تجري طبعا على شكل موجات
تتصاعد وتهبط ولكنها مستمره ومتوا والان
تشهد تصاعدا قد لا يتوقف وانا برايي اليوم
الاسرائيليون يواجهون وضعا يفشلون فيه ليل
نهار في قمع هذه المقاومه او في كسرها او
في ارهاب الفلسطينين ان يفشلون لانه كلمه
الفشل وردت على لسان المنسق الاممي للسلام
في الشرق الاوسط قال ان الفشل في احراز
تقدم سياسي للقضيه الفلسطينيه خلق فراغا
ملاهه المتطرفون من الجانبين بحسب توصيفه
وهنا اذهب الى
هل تتفق مع هذا
التقييم من الطرف المنسق الامم للسلام في
الشرق الاوسط الفشل فعلا خرق هذا الفرق
ملاه المتطرفون من الجانبين كما قال
نعم اعتقد ان هذا قول منصف واعتقدوا ان
المجتمع الدولي وتحديدا الولات المتحده
كانت مقصره في تعاملها مع الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وكان هناك
الكثير من فك الارتباط
والتخلي
واتباع مقاربه حذر اكثر من اللزوم في واقع
كان يزداد تفاقما وسوءا وحكومه نتنياهو
كانت تقدم على مقاربات اكثر خطوره في
كيفيه تعاملها مع الجوانب الامنيه وكل هذا
لم يقابل لا بتنديد كافي ومقنع من المجتمع
الدولي ولا بايه اجراءات فعاله نحن نحاول
على ما يبدو ان نبقي على هذه المشكله وهي
تحترق على نار هادئه وكل ما يجعل
المسؤولين في واشنطن يتدخلون فقط عندما
يغلي الاناء في اوقات مثلا في اروقه
القرار في لندن وفي واشنطن بهذا المعدل
البسيط واضح ان هذا لن يحل ايه مشكله
القاده هنا في واشنطن وفي العواصم
الاجنبيه الاخرى ينبغي عليهم الانخراط
اكثر والعمل من اجل نوع من التفاوض
للتعامل مع الموقف ووضع اجراءات تبني
الثقه اجراءات جديده الان نحن ننزلق الى
هاويه والى مكان لا رجعه منه الى اي امان
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هل فعلا الفشل
السياسي خلق بالفعل هذا الفراغ الذي كما
قال المنسق الاممي استغله المتطرفون من
الجانبين كما قال طبعا بتعبيره
طبعا ولكن انا لا اسميه فشل سياسي انا
اسميه اجرام اسرائيلي نسف اي فرصه لاي
عمليه سلام في المنطقه ورساله ارسلها
الاسرائيليون سمعتوها قبل قليل يقول لك
هذه اراضي اسرائيل كل فلسطين دوله اسرائيل
هي اراضيه حتى غزه بعتبرها اراضي يهوديه
اذا هذا هؤلاء الاسرائيليين ارسلوا رساله
واضحه للفلسطينيين وللعالم انه لا حل وسط
مع الفلسطينيين والحركه الصهيونيه
الغت الكذب الذي كانت تقوم به والادعاء
بانها تبحث عن حل وكشفت مواقعها انها تريد
ضم وتهويد كل فلسطين بكاملها وطبعا هذا
هذا هو الذي يؤدي الان الى تصاعد هذه
المقاومه ولكن دعيني اقول انه من ناحيه
اخرى
الوضع القائم حاليا يعود ايضا الى فشل
المجتمع الدولي في فرض عقوبات على اسرائيل
الشعب الفلسطيني ادرك قضيه بسيطه وواضحه
ان اسرائيل لا تفهم الى لغه القوه
والمجتمع الدولي ان اراد ان يكون مؤثرا
عليه ان يفرض عقوبات ومقاطعه على اسرائيل
وانا لا اقبل من السيد وينس لاند ممثل
الامم المتحده ان يساوي بين الطرفين هذا
نفاق سياسي مرفوض لا يمكن المساواه بين
الذي يمارس الاحتلال ومن هم تحت الاحتلال
من يقوم بفرض نظام ابارتايد عنصري ومن
يتعرض للاضطهاد العنصري لا يمكن المساواه
بين القاتل والشهيد الذي يتعرض للقتل كل
يوم هذا برايي مقارنه غير صحيحه وفي غير
مكانها وتمثل في الواقع انحيازا للجانب
الاسرائيلي الذي يسعده ان يتم المساواه
بينه وبين الفلسطينيين الذين
يقال دائما المفتاح في جيب واشنطن ما الذي
يمكن ان تفعلوا كيف يمكن ان تضغط على
اسرائيل
اعتقد انه هنا بيضا لديه فرصه فريده من
نوعها وذلك لان العزله التي يعاني بات
يعاني منها الان نتنياهو في واشنطن
وخسارته لقدرته على التاثير في واقع الحال
يمكنه ان يهدد او ربما يقدم على خطوات لم
تكن قابله للتصور قبل بضع سنوات فقط ربما
من خلال خطوات الدبلوماسيه معينه او الدعم
العسكري هذا سيرسل رسائل واضحه بان بايدن
جاد وعلى نعيد النظر في حساباته وبعض
خطواته وبكل صراحه اقول ان هذا سيقطع شوطا
كبيرا
للتعامل مع القضايا القضائيه والديمقراطيه
التي تحدث اسرائيل منذ اشهر لو ان واشنطن
اظهرت امام نتنياهو باننا جادون ويمكن ان
نمضي الى ما وراء مجرد الكلمات وقد نكتب
لمقاطعتك انتهى وقت البرنامج شكرا جزيلا
لك
مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في البيت
الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس الاسبق برك
اوباما ونشكر ضيفنا من رام الله دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
شكرا لكم انتم ايضا لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]